what's up YouTube as you guys all know
Andrew Tate just got arrested The Matrix
is attacking closing in on their face
too so here we're out in Boston spaniel
Hall asking people what are their
thoughts on Andrew take getting life in
prison so what are your thoughts on
Andrew Tate getting life in prison for
sex trafficking awesome awesome sauce
you saw that right no you saw that on
Tick Tock and stuff so you think he
deserves life in prison for what he's
done yeah yeah what are your overall
thoughts on Andrew Tate do you like him
or not
why don't you like him he's a bad person
why because he's a bad person he's done
bad things he's not a good person what
has he done that you personally don't
like him for talking
like you know the bad stuff
trafficking being misogynistic and such
yeah like what do you think can make
someone misogynistic like what did he
say that um makes you think that I don't
remember exactly but he got famous for
being like misogynistic yeah do you
remember anything he said specifically
nope so I'm sure you guys have heard of
him but what are your thoughts on Andrew
Tate
oh you used what do you think they are
sure you love them are you so for real
are we for real I'm being for real why
don't you like them do you like him
depends depends do you like him oh so
you like him if I like him you hate him
if I hate him no I have I have my
stances what are your thoughts so why do
you like them I don't like them because
he's a misogynist I feel like that's
I've seen that a good amount in the news
titles what about you yeah I don't know
enough about him that's fair that's so
what has he said specifically that you
don't like him for I feel like
um I don't really have to like listen to
all of his videos and like do all of
that to listen to them specifically but
reading all the articles that I've read
that works for me have you ever thought
some article titles or Clips take like
you know Clips cut up could be taken out
of context or for the most part it's the
way to pay for the most part and based
off the people that like him that also
says a lot too what if I liked him would
that that sucks for you and I really
hope that maybe you don't yeah good
thing I hate him he's a he's a
misogynist I talked to him before and he
was he was misogynistic to me isn't that
crazy
yeah
yeah it's wild but he has you just saw
him he got life in prison for sex
trafficking I'm sure you've seen that
all over social media I didn't realize
he actually went to prison for it yeah
it's crazy it's just it's like 20 over
the last 24 hours it's really new
I'm not lying to you you can look it up
right now
you promise I pinky promise
maybe I lied
[Music]
all right well thank you guys so much
for your time here do you have like a
Snapchat or anything
can I get it no no oh man is it because
I like to
well thank you guys have a good one t
you're [ __ ] selling me man what the
hell what's your name October October
I'm Sunny nice to meet you so what are
your thoughts on Andrew Tate getting
life in prison I think
I think you don't like Andrew Tate
why don't you like him because he
he goes against all publicly
he's sexist
powerful and all this [ __ ] yeah like men
should be in touch with their
masculinity and stuff like that
not a fan
what has he said that you don't
specifically like or like that sexist I
don't generally keep up with him a lot
but I know that didn't he create like a
men's club or whatever trying to promote
like oh men are better and we should
wear the superior sex and all that jazz
no he didn't well no he has like his um
organizations and stuff but it's not
just like men are better all right well
thank you for your time it was good
meeting you October I should have
introduced with my pronouns
do you like him or no hard pass hard
pass hard pass why why don't you like
them I don't appreciate his views on
women or just his concept of reality
yeah what has he said about women that
you don't like he's just made really
objectifying and negative comments about
women like anything specific
um I
it's verbatim but I just recall
different interviews where he's just
basically said that women are objects
that men possess and so that's a hard
pass for me what are your thoughts on
Andrew take getting life in prison I'm
sure you've seen it all over social
media I actually don't oh it's all good
then so what are your thoughts on Andrew
Tate you like him or passer
why don't you like him just like
how he perceives himself to the internet
how he perceives himself
like a guy who's confident or isn't
confident confident
like a guy who's strong or weak
I'm strong tall or short it's all that
can fight or can't fight
preferably it seems like you guys like
tape nice personality so what has he
said that you guys don't like there was
like there was like
like Howie would like to knock a girl I
know this might be crazy what if I told
you that clip was taken out of context
do you think that there's a possibility
that a lot of the stuff he's getting
canceled for is just taken out of
context to cancel him or do you think
it's it's truly deserved wait why did he
get life in prison that was just a joke
oh
I said you think it's possible that a
lot of the stuff he's getting canceled
for is just taken out of context and
that is just really an agenda to get
people to not like him or do you think
all the allegations are true possibly it
could go yeah it could go
I think you trust the media fully or no
do you like to say your critical
thinkers
yeah
yeah it's all good I don't even know
what to say man these people are
critical thinkers but they believe
everything that the News tells them it's
it's kind of sad everyone said he's
misogynist he's misogynist and they
haven't said one reason why like how do
you all have views and you don't even
know why like that is a problem what are
you guys thoughts on Andrew Tate have
you heard of him yes you like the guy or
no haven't heard of it in a while I feel
like there's multiple viewpoints on him
you know you see the good parts you see
the bad parts overall kind of neutral on
the guy what do you think on them um I
think that had I seen him and also a
flight of stairs he might find himself
very well accompanied with that oh man
why don't you like him
um I think it's got something to do with
him balding I don't know I don't like it
the balding so if I went bald you
wouldn't like me
oh my God so why don't you like him so
bad like what has he said that you you
disagree with so much no
no I I don't [ __ ] with people who don't
have hair I don't trust them no your own
hair doesn't like you I simply I can't I
can't support you're right this is crazy
what if I told you that he can grow hair
but he shaves it would that change
things and he's a willingly being gross
you know one thing it's like a genetic
problem like you can't really help it
and then others you choose to live that
way interesting interesting all right
maybe I'll shave my head then so have
you guys heard of Andrew Tate yeah what
are your thoughts on them he's a
misogynist yeah what happened happened
so why don't you like him because he's
pushing the wrong message to very
susceptible to yours
like what message
that
he has said things about women that are
just not okay like I don't know the
exact context but I was reading about it
and he said something about how like you
can like I don't know if it was hit
woman or like tell them that
I don't remember the context so now I
feel it's kind of like going into us
it's good it's good to talk about do you
think it's a problem to have like strong
opinions on something if you don't have
the full context and see stuff for what
it was truly meant I do but it's not
that I don't have it I just don't
remember it off the top of my head like
I have read about it I feel like
something important in this particular
situation with this is that it's not
just one situation it's a general
context of the messages that he pushes
as a general thing and but like what
specifically does he say that you don't
agree with or like
it's not true like like
but it's not just trusting me it's
trusting the facts like anyone can call
someone to go to a house and get them
arrested for something but if there's no
proof around it it doesn't make it true
I wish it was as simple as that but if
they really want him to go down for
something I'm sure they could find a way
so any other things that you could think
of why you don't like him or no I
honestly don't know a whole lot about
Andrew Tate but it's all good I'm sure
you've just seen for him in Casey sees
this video is he gonna see this video
I'm I'm like you know good friends with
them I think this is a hand message I'm
gonna give a hand message
I'm sorry no all right it was great
meeting you guys what are your thoughts
on uh Andrew Tate
um I don't like his haircut he doesn't
have a haircut yeah exactly
he's sort of just annoying he's just
annoying what do you guys like him or no
no but he has a lot of money so valid
you guys have a message for Tate in case
he might see this
be nicer to women I guess nicer to women
all right anything you want to say
top G most famous man in the world
nothing I know because I want I mean I
would love like money fly her out fly
her out tape I choose to ignore him yeah
if if that makes sense yeah he's not in
your feet or nothing no do you have any
thoughts on him
um
it's kind of gay yeah he seems gay you
think not like a bad way
it's like do the video from jumping into
like the tube like the pool
like the whole tub yeah it was kind of
sauce real quick I know a lot of you
guys don't know me for like my business
side but before starting YouTube and
everything I've generated over five
million dollars I have over 500 million
views across all my accounts I'm like a
tick tock wizard so if you guys want to
learn some of my tips learn how to make
money online I'll leave the link to my
Academy in the bio it's really cheap to
get in ton of value so make sure you
check it out any specific things you
could think of that you disagree with
well he says women who are married are
property so I don't agree with that for
sure do you want your guy to like
protect and provide for you
she gets into a fight I guess she can
protect herself
all right we won't use this on
I don't care delete it I don't want
please delete that we can't just delete
the whole thing but we we won't use it
but don't use it
I need to know who you are you are all
right
he's my name Julian
well I can show you like my YouTube if
you want so I'm sure you guys have heard
of them but what are your thoughts on
Andrew Tate
um
I mean some some of the stuff he says is
messed up but then then against some of
the other stuff's like okay you rock
with them you rock with them it's it's
like a little iffy what are your
thoughts on them I don't I don't I don't
like him why don't you like him I don't
agree with most the things he says like
anything specifically or anything on
woman anything on women so like women
are the most beautiful precious
creatures I mean I believe women are the
most precious things on the planet they
create life they should be protected
they should provide it for that you
should protect for that he uses the like
like the way that he says what they are
to him it's like disgusting to me but
like how so because you know I think
it's my job to like protect and provide
for the woman that I'm with but like
where does the line get crossed it's
like he was like making like he was like
characterizing them and saying like like
if they have more than like one body
they're like they're useless do you
think body count matters or no
no do you think body count matters no
facts I'm gonna go and find my a good
girl with like 100 bodies I'm sure you
guys have heard of him but what are your
thoughts on Andrew Tate oh
facts I don't like them either so why
don't you guys like them
what has he said that's misogynistic
that you guys don't rock with oh my God
so [ __ ] much
buddies of every single thing that comes
out of his mouth
like like anything that was [ __ ] god
awful yeah no that specific the video
yeah that was messed up anything else
specific that you don't like them for
what was it that he said about women
knowing her place or something like that
oh yeah it's every single comedy's ever
made about women yeah ballad well do you
have Snapchat or anything
yeah here throw that in there all right
well thank you guys for your time all
right have a good one I hate Tate yeah I
don't I I totally don't rock with him
either do you know who Andrew Tate is
yeah dude I love him would I would you
be shocked if I told you you were the
first pro Tate person out here all today
yeah nobody likes him anymore dude
you got this bro Andrew taste the best
bro notice how all of like the bigger
dudes or people who look like they have
more of their [ __ ] together tend to like
them and it's the crazy looking
[ __ ] that all hate tea
hilarious you can tell how they look
initially I immediately know if it's a
hit piece or some [ __ ] video oh I
know if it's a good video just from what
they look like you heard of the base
mother have you heard of the based
mother I'm sure you guys have heard of
them but what are your thoughts on
Andrew Tate
I don't think he was setting a good
example for for anyone
who do you think would be a better
example to look up to as a guy Ryan
Reynolds Ryan Reynolds
so why don't you guys like him
um
above everyone okay would you rather a
guy with confidence or looks down upon
himself confidence but not that much
okay would you rather a guy who's
stronger weak strong strong tall or
short tall can fight or can't fight
can't fight rich or not rich
it's kind of funny it seems like a lot
of these traits that you're describing
like match with it what do you think
about like you didn't say sexist or not
sexist bald or not bald not bald oh all
right well maybe that's where the line
draws I don't really care for him don't
care for him what about you seem like a
fan no don't pay attention no why don't
you like them I've heard that he's like
talking bad about girls have you heard
anything specific or you just heard he
said stuff about people
um I heard something about rape is like
voluntary and like they want it no he
didn't say that he
yeah
that's what I heard
what you heard was wrong thank you guys
so much for watching to our surprise
nobody had a good reason as to why they
don't like Tate and obviously drop in
the comments hashtag free Tate like
subscribe and I'll see y'all later
[Music]